all right guys here we go
so I am seriously exhausted I call back
from Chicago last night went to bed
super late and for those also who have
been waiting for the patron only video
on goblins and those small monsters imps
and all that stuff it's coming I was
supposed to make it today
but the whole kanye west question
required my attention I knew that I
wanted to put that out because it was
just happening right now and it's good
that I did because the the Kanye West
video has been taking off I think like
7000 views in a few hours so it seems at
least at the beginning it seems to be
doing almost as well as the Joker video
so so I guess yeah I guess commenting on
current events sometimes works so
alright so the mad truth says he wants
to post he wants to post some let's see
if it if I have it activated so the mad
truth are you trying to impose a super
chat but it's not working
all right answer that and we'll see I'll
start with questions from the different
platforms as people you know those who
give at the $10 level on each of them of
the platforms that I using they get to
ask question advance so I go through
those questions and then when those are
done then if anybody wants to put in
some super chats I will take them but as
usual if if you you know the moderators
are in Jacob is moderator he might add
another moderator as well because our
friend Kristian chad is not there today
and the moderators are in full control
if you write silly questions all right
guys so as usual I will start with my
website oh maybe one last announcement
don't forget for those who are around I
am going to be in PA and near Scranton
Pennsylvania at st. T cons in this
weekend so the conference is mostly for
the seminarians but on Sunday after
liturgy those who want to come they can
come either come to liturgy or arrive
towards the end and I will be giving
just a brief talk about you know this
kind of this strange moment where
atheists and agnostics are interested in
Christianity again and I'll also be
taking some questions so all right oh is
that what it is is it because the video
is in public let me check let me check
that might be what it is that might also
be why we don't have a lot of people in
in the event right now let me check if I
can change that
man sorry guys
Robert Smith says I'm one of seven and I
feel special all right let me check I
don't know how to change it though I
don't even if I can change oh that's
what it is
so it's not public all right so I'm
putting a public now there you go
so that should hopefully call a call to
those who haven't yeah I was like why
why is there some so people but you know
you are all of my are here on my better
friends all of you that are there right
now
uh-uh all right so we should be live now
so for anybody who is going to appear
let's see if people appear so anyways
yeah people are starting to pop in so
for those who are starting to pop in my
apologies I had not put the video live
it was only it was in not it's like
unlisted mode so I think it was only the
patrons were able to see it so I gave a
few announcements you can check them out
afterwards if you want about Santa cons
and just about being really tired in in
general so the super chat should work as
usual I'm gonna I'm going to start with
the I'm gonna start with the questions
from the website then subscribe star
then patreon and for those who want to
put in Super chats I will get to them
after that alright so here we go guys so
Keenan Cronin asked asks he mentioned in
the Halloween video that prayer is the
best way to expel the demons within us
what is it then makes prayer so powerful
okay so what is it that makes prayer so
powerful so if you look at the story in
the of the creation story in the Bible
and if you look at how Christians
believe this notion that Christ is the
incarnation of the Divine logos the idea
is that meaning and creation happens
through speaking and so the there's a
relationship between the actual
existence of the world and language that
language
which is also related to mine the
expression of mine is the manner in
which the world comes together I've
talked to you guys about that in terms
of phenomenon in general that we
participate in the oneness of phenomena
and the capacity to see the relationship
between multiplicity and unity within
something and so because language is the
way in which the relationship between
multiplicity and unity is manifest then
language is also the way to solve that
problem the problem of demons is exactly
that problem the problem with demons is
you know I sometimes I use words like
wild principalities it's the idea that
there are there are principalities the
best way to understand it is to
understand it in yourself that is you
have passions there there are things
that draw your attention and they pull
your attention in a way that fragments
you that draw you away from your heart
from your center from that which makes
you one and and like I've said before
there are cosmic versions of that so if
you if you are a slave to the demon of
lust you're not the only one
experiencing that and you know everybody
who who has that problem is having
similar experiences of reality and
that's how you can understand that it's
a demon because it's a sea it has a
cosmic aspect that personality that that
coherence of of different elements which
pulls you away from yourself
it that's death so it's a demon it's a
it's a prince it's a principality but
it's a principality that isn't submitted
that isn't submitted to the highest
thing that is it aligned with the logos
and so the way in which you get rid of
that is through speech and so of course
the the most explicit version we have is
the idea of the exorcism where someone
who has spiritual authority priest or a
saint someone who is holy will be able
to speak and will able to chase the
demon away through their authority and
so you can imagine it you know it
I think I've given this example before
it's like you if you as a father have
authority and your kids are being
naughty and and they're there they're
kind of losing control and they're
fighting amongst themselves and they're
being annoying and you say stop and if
you have authority then the word the the
speaking to them will make them stop and
they'll realign themselves and so then
that's exorcism but but altum Utley you
have to understand that when you pray
when you use language to ask of God if
you use language to ask others to
intercede for you you're you're
participating in that whole process by
which the the logos is ordering the
world and so that is why prayer is the
way to solve a lot of your problems I
mean of course demons is the most
extreme thing but a lot of your problems
are you know can be solved by prayer
because you know you have a issue and
you're even just by framing it even just
by formulating it in a request towards
God then you are opening up that space
for the logos to come and manifest
himself one of the examples I've given
before is in the wedding of Cana where
Christ is hidden no one knows that he's
the divine logos and the mother of God
Mary she comes up to him and she says
there's a problem there's no wine and
it's like and then cracks it then Christ
at first is saying you know it's not my
time yet
because she is she is opening up the
space for him to reveal himself and when
he said it's not my time yet is because
he's going to reveal himself unto death
but this ode this idea that you have to
further for the for the logos to
manifest himself manifest himself in the
world there has to be a prayer there has
to be a space a body call it a body a
prayer is a body prayer is like here's a
frame I want meaning to manifest itself
in that frame so I hope that that makes
sense and it's you know and and if you
pray to God that that is the ultimate
example that is the highest example
where you're really submitting yourself
to the highest of high but you can pray
to your boss right you have a problem
someone's being annoying in the office
or maybe there aren't enough staples in
the office and so you need to solve that
problem well how do you solve the
problem you ask your boss because your
boss has the authority to give you
staples and so the idea that through
prayer to asking you we solve problems
is just it's something we experience all
the time we if we we just have to be
able to see it in the highest sphere and
in the cosmic element of it which is
really prayer to the the divine but
people like the idea that that the idea
that we should only pray to God is
really silly
nobody only prays to God it's just
anybody who thinks they only prayed to
God is really deluding themselves you
pray all the time to all you know you
you pray when you go to the store you
pray when you you you pray to your boss
you pray to your politicians you pray in
your app you ask things of those that
are higher than you that are higher up
than you in the hierarchy and that's a
form of Prayer the fact that we've made
it special for God is is anyways once
you know where I think that comes from
so anyways so alright enough on that my
goodness but I just spent 15 minutes on
that one question all right I need to
not do that again all right here we go
so alright so let me see did everything
work out in terms of the in terms of the
the the chat and the the anyway the
payment and stuff anyways we'll see
we'll see you later all right if there's
a problem guys tell me okay I'll try to
keep my eye on the for the super chats
okay so DS brew asks hi Jonathan
have you by chance read the book
orthodoxy and the religion of the future
by Seraphim my father's cell from Rose
if so what were your thoughts if not
could you be able to talk a bit
Prevost and spiritual spiritual
deception how might a proper symbolic
worldview help an honest seeker discern
what is true across a huge landscape of
spiritual experiences PS we're still
waiting for that symbolism of Antichrist
666 video to drop well I read parts of
that book I am I haven't read the whole
thing after you honest with you it is
one of the books on my list and I very
much do want to read it um and if you
want me to I think that what I've read
and what I've gathered from the content
that he does in fact deal with the
problem of kind of this weird spiritual
but not religious moment you know the
kind of New Age the strange new age for
sure his intuition that the future would
not be secular was right and we see that
not only in father Seraphim rose but you
see it also in the [ __ ] know who had
who had influence on seraphim rose in
terms of that book and what I've read of
Orthodoxy and the religion of the future
resembles Ginn owns the reign of
quantity and the signs of time and the
signs of the time and so I think that we
are surrounded by pre lest and spiritual
deception and I I totally agree and I
think it is probably important that I
talk about that a little more I haven't
been talking about it very much just
because it has been on the subject but I
do think that this might also be a
problem for all of you guys that are
really into psychedelics I would say
that you know I've never taken
psychedelics so III don't want to speak
without experience but what I gather
from what I hear is that it does seem to
open people up to spiritual experiences
now the problem with having spiritual
experiences is you need discernment and
one of the ways to have discernment is
to be connected to be connected to a
hierarchy to be connected to a clear
path a clear tradition and to you know
to hopefully to have a spiritual father
or a confessor that can help you get
through those types of experiences now
not everybody has um not everybody has
access to that
but for sure I think it's important to
understand that in the the Christian
tradition the Church Fathers really warn
against spiritual experiences they're
not saying that they're inauthentic but
they they use they tend to say that you
shouldn't really try to grasp those
experiences too much that is the purpose
of the mystical life or the purpose of
the spiritual life is to be united with
with God is to be transformed to be free
from your passions to be illumined with
with the fullness of the divine to the
extent that that's possible and that is
very different than a kind of mystical
vision that you would have you know
mystical visions can be helpful and you
know in the Orthodox tradition there are
plenty of mystical visions which are
used to to interpret to interpret some
of the tradition with those visions but
like I said that's not the point the
point is not to have these visions and
as we and it and it's important not to
simply trust those visions especially
because you know if you don't already if
you haven't reached a certain spiritual
level and you had these experiences you
don't have the capacity to know what the
wheat and what the chaff is and when I
you know and to be honest when I hear a
lot of the psychedelics people
especially the the really famous ones I
hear a lot of chaos and I hear you know
when people talk about what is it the
clockwork elves and all of that stuff I
don't hear a lot of good stuff coming
out of that not in terms of spiritual
transformation all right okay so still
waiting for the the the I I will make a
video on on 666 at some point I've been
wanting to make it for a while
it just seems like there's so many
things to talk about it's hard to get to
all of these but one day I will
if censorship gets worse even that it is
now you might see me making video about
that because it's related actually to
some of the censorship that we've that
we've been seeing alright david Flores
says
Gawain and the Green Knight video please
yeah that's coming I'll make a video on
that subject for sure especially maybe a
patron only video will see I'm
definitely interested in that um so last
Q&A I realize that when you say
hierarchy I'm misunderstanding exactly
what you mean my assumption is that you
mean a hierarchy for a given problem
concept idea hierarchy of truth but I
feel like you sometimes mean something
like the hierarchy of hierarchies I'm
sure this qualifies more for a video due
to the complexity but can you expound on
how you conceptualize and apply
hierarchy so I mean I think you're right
I think I think that I when I talked
about hierarchy I'm in a way I'm talking
about um the UM the meta hierarchy or a
meta pattern and it is important to
understand that because because there's
the higher there's the hierarchies
themselves and then there's the very
manner in which hierarchies are made
which is analogical across the different
hierarchies so if you have a political
hierarchy or you have the hierarchy of
the person or you have the hierarchy of
the temple they all share certain things
in common they're not exactly the same
they all share certain things in common
which as you can see the analogies
between the different hierarchies then
you can start to understand hierarchy
per se or the you know the divine
hierarchy which is the highest form of
hierarchy but another important thing
about that is also to understand that I
mentioned that word a few times I talked
about the meta pattern a few times in
the in the recent videos and I realized
when I was saying it that I'm like maybe
these these guys I'm not telling them
what I mean by that word but when I when
I use the words when I use a word like
meta pattern what I mean is that it's
it's the hierarchy and the manner in
which the hierarchy breaks down and so
there's a pattern and then there's the
breakdown of the pattern but my
contention from the beginning has been
that the breakdown of a pattern is also
part of a bigger pattern in which you
can see how that breakdown occurs
so even the chaos is ultimately part of
it meta pattern you would say because
you can you can recognize chaos and you
can recognize not total chaos as you
can't see absolute chaos but you can
recognize the effects of chaos or the
breakdown of structures you it happens
in a way which is coherent and you can
you can see across different types of
hierarchies so I hope that answers that
alright so I'm moving to subscribe star
okay so XRD asks your word of warning in
your Halloween video about becoming too
obsessed with the holiday makes me think
about the contemporary obsession with
content that appeals to our nostalgia
sometimes something about it feels wrong
but I can't quite put my finger on it
and you thought uhm yeah I agree I agree
I don't think I don't know if there's
directly a relationship between
Halloween but I do think that there is a
problem with nostalgia one of the things
that sometimes I I say is I believe in
tradition without nostalgia because the
problem with nostalgia is that you you
attach yourself to something in the past
there's this longing for the past
and sometimes it's sent it's it's just
sentimental thing you're not it's not
for understanding the past or it's not
for actualizing it now but it's a kind
of sadness of a loss for something
that's behind us now I do believe that
that type of nostalgia is can be useful
spiritual the in terms of you know
people talk about the nostalgia for
Paradise I think that it can be it can
be useful if we live in that nostalgia
for Paradise but I think that that type
of nostalgia can be directed in a wrong
way and you see it in for example people
who like old things you know and it's
hard for people to be able to see the
difference between tradition and old
things people traditional cultures
didn't didn't care that much for old
things unless those old things had a
very important meaning and so it can
sometimes bath
all modern people to understand that you
know when a church got old or was too
small they would they knock it down and
build a bigger one on top and it was not
for them a big problem you know it
wasn't like we need to absolutely
preserve everything from the past just
because it's old because we the living
tradition is living and so if a church
is too small
knock it down make a bigger one if you
know if the church needs to be restored
it's like restore it you don't have to
preserve everything you you paint new
frescoes you you do all that if it's
there's a need to if there's no need
then you don't do it but it's not about
being you know is it tradition is
actually diametrically opposed to a kind
of archeological obsession with you know
this kind of weird preservation of
monuments and this kind of strange
desire to to preserve things just
because they're old but I mean in the
end I would much rather they do that
because modern buildings and a lot of
modern stuff is so ugly so that I'm
sometimes thankful for those
preservation societies who want to
preserve old buildings you don't even
know exactly what's motivating them
except for some kind of sentimentality
but it I'd rather have that old building
than whatever a condo is going to
replace it so so yeah so sometimes thank
God for that
okay so Nicola asks can you explain the
difference between the soul and the
spirit
I was always confused about that ever
since I was a kid um so at least in the
Orthodox tradition we have this idea
that the word spirit in this in the way
that Paul uses it I would say has we has
been come to be called something like
that the news or the intellect and so
the spirit would be the highest aspect
of you and that highest aspect is a kind
of direct intuition of the patterns of
reality a capacity to have direct
intuition with the the logos and the
loci that are hidden in creation um and
so there there are things that we do you
know some types of prayers with out
there with the Church Fathers talk about
purifying the news
that is kind of getting to the core of
the the of the spirit so the problem
that we have that most of us don't have
access to the spirit very often in a way
we do all the time when we don't realize
it because the our noetic capacity this
the absolutely spiritual capacity
actually you know the hidden identities
of things and our capacity to interact
with them is actually informing our
entire experience of the world but
usually we live in what you would call
the soul part which is your thoughts
your emotions your personality all of
these things are in the soul part and
you'll read in the Church Fathers
they'll say things like you are not your
thoughts you're not your feelings you
are not you know your thoughts are not
you you you the highest aspect of you is
beyond is beyond the dialectic of
thinking it's beyond the dialectic of
emotions and it's this direct capacity
to encounter reality you kind of catch
it and so we have little glimpses of
that I mean every time you get this
sense you know when you have that little
spark moment when everything comes
together and you get this it's kind of
like a magical moment where you grasp
something it's like aha you know you get
this little this little spark you're
you're kind of you're kind of flirting
with the news here you're coming up to
it you know but the Church Fathers talk
about how it is possible to fully enter
into the heart and to hold in the heart
and to have a to be transformed in a
manner in which you have always have
access to this noetic capacity all right
and so Nicola also asks the creator of
our faith States towards the end that
Christ will come again in glory to judge
living in the dead and his kingdom will
have no end you please elaborate on the
touching the living and the dead section
particularly the dead part if the data
to be judged again that would imply that
there could be rearranging of one's
place and the kingdom to come whether up
or down the latter am I reading too much
into this and is there a better way of
picturing this
well I mean these things are difficult
to talk about and sometimes you get get
into serious trouble talking about them
and so I don't want to get into this the
way that I like to explain it and the
way that I like to describe it is my own
and so take it for what it is it's your
lumen on that is a theological opinion
as I ponder the mysteries of reality the
way that I understand it is you have to
see the end a good way to understand it
would be to understand to a certain
extent how your end coincides with the
end that is that as you come to the end
of you is the totality of your
possibilities which are consummated that
is everything that was going to be you
has gone as run its course and you
you've come to thee and you have the
totality I don't know if you understood
I mean but it's like it's like I can say
this is all you there's no more coming
there's no there's not there's nothing
left there's nothing more coming of you
in a kind of manifestation and that is
the end and so if you can understand it
in a way that that end is the same for
everything that is everything has an end
every identity has an end every person
every city every country every every
everything has an end and and as you
come to that end that end coincides with
the eschaton and I some people are going
to be angry that I described it that way
whatever I'm just I'm this is the way
that that I am capable of making it make
sense in my mind that is all these ends
they coincide with what we call the
eschaton which is the return of the logo
to judge everything - - and and you can
understand it like
that while something has body that is
you while you have body the logos acts
as your guide acts as it also has a a
kind of it's a call it's a call to come
towards the logos and so there is a kind
of grace there's a kind of compassion so
so Christ appears to you as as as as
saint come you know wanting you to come
towards him to the extent that you can
but then once you're finished once you
want to come to the end of something
then that identity that logos becomes
your judge so you can think about it you
can think about it in any way you can
think about it as think about it as a
play or a movie it's like as you're
watching the movie let's say ah through
the whole movie you you leave open your
judgment right unless it's really
horrible then you maybe start judging
before the end but usually what you try
to do is you try to leave your judgment
open because you haven't gotten the
whole story and so a good example of a
movie is like a movie like The Sixth
Sense where it's you stop in the middle
of the movie and you judge it you would
get it wrong no you have to leave
yourself open and and kind of engage
with the movie until it ends but once it
ends then the logos of the story becomes
judge then the logos now judges and
there's a judge let's say the logos of
movies judges that movie because it now
acts as a standard that you have or have
not reached while you're climbing the
ladder it's it's it's not yet a judge
it's only at the end that it acts as a
judge because all now everything is done
and the standard appears as that which
you haven't reached or kin shows you the
extent to which you've reached that
standard so I hope I hope that makes
sense that's the way that I understand
it I hope this is helpful if
not sorry but there are plenty of places
where you can find the kind of more
traditional description which is usually
described more narrative Lee and I have
no problem with the more narrative
description of the life after death and
you know either the tow house is a
purgatory or this is this kind of
playing out in the afterlife of the
consequences of your life moving all the
way towards the Last Judgement which is
the place where everything is evaluated
alright so I hope that helps
so Nicola asked you have any advice on
how to talk about relics to my fiancee
who it's not religious at all her and I
have had long talk about Orthodox
beliefs and she finds them a bit weird
but otherwise tries to remained as
neutral as she can when she found out
about relics though we have one at our
church he was afraid and couldn't
explain why she felt that way she used
to work as a paramedic and she was
dumbfounded why she would feel this way
I've consulted our priests about the
whole thing but I couldn't get any
concrete advice I was mostly advised to
be patient loving and kind and that God
will sort things out um all right I
talked about relics a few times before
and I and I really understand why relics
are such a problem um I would say that
it is important not to completely shy
away from the horror that really create
in us I think that that is not I think
that that is part of relics the idea of
a relic is that death can be changed
into glory that's what a relic is and
the very death of the saint becomes his
glory now you can see it this way see it
like this his body let's say a Saints
body dies and then the very
flesh the very bones the nails the very
hairs the you know the flesh like really
the body in the in the in the most
physical natural sense is taken parts
are taken and are sent out all around
and those relics become the the place
the Holy it's officially the Orthodox
Church they become the anchor of
holiness in a church and so either under
the altar there has to be a Saints relic
for for the liturgy to occur sometimes
it's it's sewn into the cloth which is
put on the altar and that's what it is
it is the transformation of death into
glory it is the very hope of what
Christianity is and we have to be
careful not to like I said to shy away
from what it what it is in the sense
that there is something shocking just
like communion is shocking relics are
also shocking but they are an image of
how the highest and the lowest meet
together of how the very body dead body
of someone can actually participate in
anchoring a community and participate in
the glory that Christ brings into the
world that's the best way I can explain
it so I hope that helps I know some
people will never will never totally
understand it and I think that to a
certain extent it is it is Ness is not
necessarily possible to fully understand
it but if we are non-dual like if we if
we do not believe that duality is the or
is at the beginning of reality if we
don't believe that the world is defined
in ultimately in duality that although
there are dual isms that they don't they
don't end in duality that the thing that
they P
into God then we have to understand that
everything participates ultimately and
that just as glory was changed into
death at the fall so to death is changed
into glory so that's the best I can do
alright so I'm moving now to patreon
okay so drew McMahon asks any thoughts
on the any thoughts on the pocke mama
pagan statue stolen from the Catholic
Church and thrown in the Tiber River is
this breaking a commandment or following
one I feel like the Catholic Church is
fractured my goodness
what a mess this whole Park uh mama
thing is okay I'm not gonna give you I'm
not gonna give you a total answer I'm
not gonna give you a total answer to
this but okay I'm gonna first give the
be careful answer because I see a lot of
trads going nuts a lot of treads that
are you know that are simply declaring
their righteousness without thinking
about it or without examining themselves
we have to be aware that some of the
titles that we use for the mother of God
that we use for Mary were titles that
were used for ancient pagan goddesses
right so so we have to be careful and to
be aware of that and so we have to
understand that Christianity we're not
Protestants we don't believe that
Christianity simply exists in this pure
fashion that it somehow has a pure form
that is Scripture I guess I don't know
it has a pure form and that anything
that is not from that pure form
contaminates it we we don't believe that
we believe that Christianity like
baptism has a transformative effect on
whatever culture it encounters that it
takes that which in it takes that
culture and it plunges it into the
waters of death and it pulls out from
that baptism whatever it is that is can
be taken for it can be compatible and so
you can understand for example that a
good way to see it is that if in the
first century the Son of God was
Augustus the Son of God was Caesar
Augustus he was the first one to be
called the son of God and so medieval
Christians saw the the Aeneid which
talks about Augustus as the son of God
they saw it as a prophecy for Christ
because they're saying the notion of the
Son of God is not a is not a bad one you
just have the wrong you have the wrong
manifestation the real son of God has
something much more because he unites
the king and the crucified one he unites
everything together he's not just an
emperor he he is the top and the bottom
he's the Alpha and Omega
and-and-and-and declaring that that is
that is more than the way that Romans
understood the notion of the Son of God
now it's the same also for Mary what
happened is that all the aspects of
feminine symbolism which were there
before and which were useful and which
were close to truth were taken back were
cleansed were pruned were removed of
their dangerous elements and were then
applied in a proper manner to the mother
of god who is the temple who is the ark
who is the space in which the divine
manifests himself and so that's the
that's the answer so we need to be
careful okay
need to be careful now there is the
danger of the opposite of what I just
said which is if Christianity takes that
the that from the culture which it
encounters that ties it and brings it
into the faith we have to be careful
that we don't do the opposite that we
don't denature ourselves that we don't
denature the core of what Christianity
is in order to then give it to these
pagan gods with these pagan things do
you see the difference between the two
and so and so we we're not going to say
that that Mary is an image of this
mother goddess paka mama or whatever
that is blasphemy that is a that is not
Christian that is a denaturing of
Christianity now would it be possible
for those tribal people to understand
through paka mama - to come to
understand what the role of the mother
of God is because maybe there are some
things which aligned with that that
could be possible now is that what is
that what's happening now it seems that
it's not seem that's what's happening is
rather this denaturing which that these
tribal group and i don't know because
i'm not there and in a lot of everything
that's been written has been written in
terms of polemic but it seems like
what's happening is that the the tribal
group is using the fact that we have the
mother of God the Virgin Mary in
Christianity to justify their worship of
this mother goddess which they just keep
as their own now that is the
understanding that I have and I would
say that whether or not that's that's
what's happening I would say that that
is the danger and that is the
opportunity on one side and that is the
danger on the other side so so yeah so
but what I'm seeing it seems to be that
as Pope Francis
quite a bit and that many modern
Catholic seems to do they seem to
actually want to evacuate Christianity
for that which comes from the outside
and I would say that that is a form of
that is a form of sacrilege all right
and so Benjamin Wood says I probably
share your view that things will get
worse before they get better
what are your thoughts on approaches
like Dreier's Benedict option and
forming intentional communities as a
strategy for navigating the potentially
destructive years ahead
sometimes I sometimes think it's wise
and sometimes think it's cowardice I
think that you know and I've had some
discussions with rod about this and I
kind of hadn't read his book I kind of
came in with the basic idea that he was
asking people to retreat from society
and in discussion with him he vehemently
said that that is really not what it's
about and that is not what he is
suggesting that rather he he doesn't see
these communities that are formed as
isolating themselves from the modern
world but rather giving themselves a
coherence and a strength in order to
interact with the modern world in a
stronger and more coherent manner and I
think in that sense that it's that it's
good if you can do it if it can happen
it's not available to everybody it is
one of the dangers that I see maybe and
that is for example I'll give you an
example like I am constantly tempted to
move to South Carolina like if I had if
I had reason to I would be I would go to
South Carolina why because in South
Carolina there are these amazing
Orthodox churches with beautiful
communities beautiful churches painted
icons you know people who who help each
other people who who see themselves as
this strong community way more than
anything I can find in the North in that
more than most people are able to find
in the north and so it's like okay I'm
gonna move to Charleston or to
Greenville where I know there are these
amazing communities but the problem we
have to be also careful that you know we
also don't want to leave if all the
Christians leave and go to where those
those groups are you're also kind of
evacuating you're kind of abandoning
your own nations your own in your own
communities and so I don't know I don't
know I mean for now I'm still here and I
and I have no intention to go and I'm
also I've decided now I'm going to try
to also have some meetups here of people
curious people agnostics atheists
anybody who was interested to discuss
because I feel like maybe I'm more
useful actually out here than I would be
if I was in a great community with a
bunch of you know extremely engaged
Orthodox people so yeah I don't know all
right
so Benjamin would also ask people like
yourself and Jordan Peterson and health
help me grok I think there's an error I
have met help me get the value of
tradition hierarchy etc I see now the
Pandora's box of subjectivity that has
gradually been open in the West over the
last millennium and the harm it has
wrought that said I'm still a southern
American and Anglo scots-irish descent
who has individual sovereignty and
rebellion to what's perceived to be
arbitrary central authority encoded in
my DNA I can't help but see some virtue
and discuss skeptical streak as the
individual level but also perceive the
chaos it can manifest at the collective
layer level do you have any advice on
how to order these things within myself
especially as I approach faith and the
church and I think that I think that we
do need kind of balance and and I don't
think that especially for those who
aren't monks who you know let's say
we're not monastics there has to be
balance
between a capacity to submit to
Authority and to submit to a tradition
and also have a sphere of a private
sphere of private experiences and so you
know the modern world doesn't only
appear as this Pandora's box of
subjectivity as you mentioned the modern
world appears as both and though we're
just lucky right now to a certain extent
maybe we're unlucky but we're just lucky
that we are now in the the swing of the
pendulum or the space on the map where
the extreme subjectivity is manifesting
itself but if you were in you know if
you were in the in the Eastern Europe
just you know a few decades ago if you
had been in Germany a few decades ago
you would have seen the other side of
this pendulum and you know a lot of
people are feeling that that the other
side of the pendulum is coming and it
might be coming faster than we expect
and so I think that value that balance
is the is the key and but it's hard
because it's not there is no there is no
specific rule because it all depends on
the circumstance it all depends on the
situation and here's here's one place
where I think that John for Becky's idea
about optimal grip or this idea of you
know I forget some of the technical
words uses but the idea that that you
your attention or your capacity to be
ordered will always be in relation to
what is there as as what's happening in
front of you so sometimes you have to be
more let's say submitted to your
authority and then other times you may
have to be more skeptical to your
authority because sometimes the
authority is corrupt we saw that in the
Catholic Church and we see it in the
Orthodox Church and the you know that
and even in terms of a corrupt Authority
there are some places where you still
would need to submit yourself to the
extent that that corrupt Authority is is
at least speaking in line with tradition
but there are certain ways in which you
should definitely not submit to those
corrupt authorities you know Christ
talks about when he talked about the
Pharisees he says do what they say but
do not what they do he says because they
sit in the seat of Moses because even
though our authorities ya know if a
policeman gives you a ticket for
speeding and you were speeding you know
and if you find out that that policeman
is corrupt and it's taking drug money or
whatever you still speed you were still
speeding and you still have to accept
that ticket from that cop you know but
you do have to find the balance alright
so I hope this makes sense so Robert
Smith's says is there something symbolic
in the phrase of scales falling from the
eyes
is there something symbolic in the
phrase I mean I've heard several people
use that phrase I've heard joint
peterson use it i think he he takes it
from young who takes it from Gnostic
texts the idea that that when Adam and
Eve fell that the scales fell from their
eyes
you know you of course the let's say the
the way that it's described is meant to
talk about the snake it's you know it's
as if this this skin of the snake has
fallen and there's this kind of opening
and this renewal there's a capacity to
see the things more directly and so what
the Gnostics have tend to understand is
that that is somehow good that and
that's where you get you get this idea
that the fall of Adam and Eve somehow is
actually good and it's a very dangerous
way to think because sin Ephraim this
here and really gives the best
description of this problem he says that
we were meant to be given the fruit of
the knowledge of good and evil we were
meant to know that is the scale that the
scales from our eyes were meant to fall
and for us to be able to see that's a
duality but
we were meant to see it from the space
of unity that is we were if we had
submitted to the higher principle if we
had submitted to the principle the the
law of God that the divine logos if we
had submitted to that then in eating the
Tree of Life
God would have also given Adam and Eve
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil so that from a place of unity they
would have seen duality now the problem
of the scale from falling from their
eyes and being revealed the mysteries of
the of duality without being in a place
of unity is that they fell into the
duality they became prisoners of their
revelation because they and then when
they saw the unity when they looked up
and they saw God they were they were
afraid and they wanted to hide
themselves and so I think it's really
important to - and you see it now you
see it you see this kind of stuff all
the time and I and I think this is also
some of the mysteries of that one of the
attractions of things like the occult
for people is that some of the mysteries
that that say occult writers have
revealed or have helped people revealed
to see are real that is they they're
they're they're you know you can
encounter a demon if you make the effort
and you you do all the proper things you
will you will encounter a demon and it
will be scales falling from your eyes
but if you're if you're not if you're
not in the a higher place when you
encounter a demon that demon will eat
you and so it's I hope that that answers
that I hope that that answers that all
right all right so drew McMahon asks
another questions so it appears that
Kanye will convert more people to
Christianity than anyone else in this
generation what is going on well you
guys I mean I don't really have to
answer the question drew I think you
probably asked this question before I
made the video you guys check out the
video that I I made today on Kanye and
I've been watching Kanye for a very long
time so you will see what I think about
him has a is a foolish as a fool
character but I do agree I do think that
I've been seeing it come for quite a
while and you know my desire to connect
with Jordan Peterson my talking about
people like Gavin McGinnis and even Milo
and all these characters that appeared
in the last few years on the horizon
they're all part of bringing us towards
this flip this renewal that I think is
going to happen I don't know how big
it's going to be I don't know if I don't
know if it's only going to be the
forming of a remnant I'm not sure but um
I think it's inevitable and and if Kanye
participates in that well I guess it
glory to God I guess you know all right
okay so mark Peters axe Jonathan in a
recent video you were talking about the
body and said something to the effect
that the body doesn't really matter it's
neutral then you said the soul is the
body of the word or the soul is the body
of this I would have I probably I
probably didn't say that probably said
the soul is the body of the noose or the
soul is the body of the spirit okay then
I thought you said in the soul body
relationship that the body is masculine
mmm no no all right I understood what I
understood you to mean that the
masculine feminine dyad is mutable
according to with the relation in focus
yes that you understood the tabernacle
is feminine in receiving the Holy of
Holies but masculine in relation to the
rest of creation it struck me that your
initial character characterization of
the body as being neutral with
diminutive importance some active
Cartesian dualism so no no it's there is
no there is no Cartesian dualism you
know and I'm not making this up you know
it Aristotle the thought of the body
that way thought of the notion of matter
that way that is there is everything has
an aspect of it which is
and so that matter is matter to that
principle but it can it not know it can
act as something else for a lower that's
a reality and so the in terms of us are
physical or physical body it's it's
neutral in the sense that it receives
its direction and it receives from above
and you it only becomes negative if the
hierarchy is not right that is that if
your soul focuses more on your body then
folk then focusing on that which
elevates it towards the spiritual or the
news or you're just literally you know
brings it up towards God if you your
eyes are always turned towards the body
then that's when the body becomes a
problem because it's pulling your
attention in the wrong directions and
there's nothing wrong with having some
attention to your body but it has
everything
things have to be aligned in the right
direction if they're misaligned and you
your soul focuses on your body then
that's when that's when then that's when
food becomes a problem that's when sex
becomes a problem that's when all these
things which are not bad in themselves
there's nothing wrong with any of these
things that that's when they become a
problem so I hope that helps okay so
Tyson and Jessica Gabe asks what does a
proper interpersonal relationship with
principalities bodyless powers and
saints look like from your perspective
with regard as I'm sorry I'm laughing
guys cuz these questions man they're
great you guys have the best questions
but some someone that are tough all
right with regards to this could you
expound on tamata and votive offerings
in orthodoxy what is to Matta I don't
know that is it's a votive
I don't think I've never never used the
word Tama tamata Tama
okay what is the relation between that
and principalities okay so how can I
explain this so it's actually very
similar to prayer if I can understand
prayer maybe that can help you
understand this notion of a votive so
for those who don't know these these
Tama that she talks about these votive
offerings what they are is usually they
are something like little images like
little body parts let's say of someone
who is sick if their arm hurts they'll
have a little image of an arm if they if
they have certain problems there'll be
little images of the things that they
that they have a problem with which with
which they will offer to they'll offer
to a saint they'll off they'll bill
they'll put it next to an icon they'll
they'll bring it they'll bring it to a
church step you know sometimes you see
churches where these little votives are
put on different places they're nailed
there or they're stuck there or whatever
and so like can I expand to this so so
this is this is some of the hard stuff
because this is the type of stuff it for
modern people looks like superstition
and I can understand why people would
view it that way but I want maybe I can
explain it to you
in the way that I talked about before
when I talked about prayer and when I
talked about the idea of understanding
prayer as the the opening up of a space
for the logos to manifest themselves in
right it's like here's a problem God
here's a problem do something about it
and so it's this it's it's it's it's
creating a body for God to manifest
himself in now the this idea of a votive
is related to that it's like so your arm
hurts right and so you can't put your
arm like you can't put your you can't
cut your arm off and say God fix my arm
you know you can't offer up that body in
a physical manner you can do it in
prayer you can do it in word but you
know ultimately what you would want to
do is you would want to take whatever
problem you have and like put it out
there and say God or you know st. X like
can you pray for me about this can you
help me with this this is where I need
help and so because we can't do that
there's a secondary manner in which
people will do that which is to have a
little image of an arm and to a little
image of eyes or a little image a little
image of you or a little image of a baby
that you know a mother who wants to who
doesn't want to lose her pregnancy and
it's like you put that out there and
you're like this this is the thing that
I want you to help me with and so it's
like you're offering up body you're
offering up space you're offering up the
frame in which you want the light to
shine in in which you want the the
divine logos to manifest themselves so
that's that's that's what it is now does
it have a relationship with
principalities I mean to a certain
extent or they're Saints in the sense
that you know just
just like this is a good idea like this
is a good way to understand it's like if
you went to the doctor and you had a
problem with your arm then you would say
here's my arm doctor fix my arm right
and so if you have a bodyless
principality if you want to ask the
intercession of a saint if you want to
ask for a saint to pray for you
regarding this problem that you have
then like I said you can't do that so
it's like here's this image of an arm
that I'm putting on the icon of this
saint in order to open up the space for
the saint to pray for me so that
ultimately it's God who will act through
the prayers of this saint on my arm
that's what it is and and it's like and
you guys are really pushing this because
I feel like as you as if those who've
been following me for a while like I've
been trying to explain these things
gradually you know one step at a time so
that is that those of you that are more
natural natural ists or that are more
skeptical or more kind of agnostic will
understand where I'm going so I feel
like in this answer I'm kind of jumping
a few steps for you guys is that a lot
of you might go oh my goodness like this
guy's crazy but you know if you keep
following me at some point where it will
get there to understand once you
understand God once you understand there
that there is a connection between the
way the world exists and mind and
language these things can never be
totally disconnected then there there
are these types of practices will start
to be less strange to you now I have to
admit I don't engage in those practices
because I'm still a very modern person
because I am I am someone who is very
intellectual and so I I'm not uh I don't
have that kind of extremely I'm not as
have that as grounded of a can I say
this grounded religion like people did
in the old days or people even sometimes
still have in Greece or in Russia
in in the old country you would say but
I don't have a problem with it I I don't
think that I think it would be naive to
believe that it's just superstition or
that it doesn't work it's no more
superstition than prayer you know it's
it's the same thing as prayer it's just
done in a matter which is an offering up
of an image or offering up of a part of
something so that you open up that space
so all right guys hope that makes sense
and sorry if I'm losing you here cuz I
didn't necessarily expect to talk about
something like that alright so I am I'm
already done with the question so let's
go into the let's go into the super
chats and and see what we got
so I saw the Christian Chad showed up
Christian all right
how could he see you I saw a bunch of
you guys from the sub saw Brad Iceman is
there and I saw some of you guys from
the from the Facebook group I'm really
excited to see how the the Facebook
group has been has been growing so if
you guys aren't on the Facebook group
you want to have discussions about this
stuff that's that's definitely the place
to be right now
I think I saw Lisa is there too so all
right here we go that's what I'm alright
okay so here we go I'm gonna go down to
the first one start with the first one
okay so we've
got a few that are that have been
deleted I told you guys we watch out
with the watch out for the moderators
you know if you think that you're if you
think that you're your super chat
shouldn't be deleted what I would
suggest is that sign up for me on one of
my platforms for just one month ask your
question on that platform at ten dollars
a month you can just pay ten dollars
because you guys are some of you
spending more than that just ask your
question and then I will I will I will
be the final judge to decide but in the
meantime on the super chats
I totally trust Jacob and and Kristian
Chad so so that's the reality okay here
we go so point curation asks thoughts on
West world and the problem with future
game and PCs being capable of suffering
I don't think we're there but someday we
will be oh man seriously point creation
I got better things to think about that
future game and VC's suffering they're
there they're quite a few people
suffering in the world right now how can
I answer this how can I answer this so
that I'm giving you something because I
feel like I need to give you something
here I would say that the whole AI
question is is definitely extremely
important and and it's something that
that we need to think about and it's
something that is going to create is
going necessarily going to create
monsters in the sense that I've talked
about monsters very close to the sense
also of the notion of principalities
which join with lower bodies bodies that
are too low for them and you know the
idea of the fall of the Angels I think
that when we look at AI we're
approaching that type of problem it
might happen through us and the very
fact that we're asking these types of
questions and that you know jejak is
asking whether or not sex robots have
rights whether or not
you know and that what did Tim Cook is
talking about the god from the machine
it's gonna end up saying more about how
fallen we are um but we might still
manifest a demon just by that type of
interaction just by the fact that we we
look at that so yeah anyways my video
will come on that guy so sorry if I'm
being esoteric here
there's nothing esoteric you know what
I'm saying alright so Stan the one and
only for $5 says JP I'm bummed that I
missed your recent Chicago appearance
hope you had a great trip keep up the
good work Thank You Stan Alyosha $30 and
no message Thank You Ally oh sure that
is very kind of you
Devere 2777 says I'm a former Gnostic
trained Orthodox Christian but if a
legume anon I've kept from my apocryphal
days is a belief that the Holy Spirit is
female would you say that this is an
acceptable belief for an Orthodox
Christian to have would say no I would
say it isn't I would say that your
desire to find the feminine in God is
understandable I understand it I don't
think it's the Holy Spirit I think that
my goodness I think that the manner in
which Christianity is manifest the
feminine it's in its theology is is
through deification that is the way that
the feminine appears in Christianity we
have to see the feminine in the big
eternal story as the capacity for that
which is not God by nature to be unified
with God and and I think that that's the
way we have to understand the feminine
and and the only way to totally get it
is to get it in the entire cosmic story
and to understand that the very purpose
of creation is that this potentiality
which this overflowing of God that is in
the Eternity in the in the infinite of
God there there it's like there even had
to be that which is not his nature but
also fully participates in God and so it
is this it is this eternal love story
it's like this giant love story that is
being told this massive love story and I
think that that is the way that we need
to see the the way that the feminine
plays a part in Christianity now
the problem and I've talked about this
recently the problem is that it's
difficult to talk about the feminine
should always be difficult to talk about
and we should we always be careful not
to have clear pronouncement about the
feminine because that the very point of
the feminine is to elude clear
pronouncement and so and so we we have
to be very careful so if you notice my
talks I point I I allude I give
analogies I do all that but but I'm very
careful not
to try to point to let's say the Divine
Feminine because every time you do that
you end up in trouble and yeah that's
about as much as I'm gonna say on that
subject so Christian Chad for $10 good
to see you Christian hi Jonathan I'm
looking into the fasting and diet of
Orthodoxy I'm curious why it's basically
vegan even outside Easter for most of
the year this is because meat is
symbolically unclean thoughts it's not
mostly vegan I mean the fasting yeah the
fasting of Orthodoxy is vegan the life
of work that actually is not vegan you
have to understand the the it's not that
meat is symbolically unclean it's that
there is this idea that that in the
garden humans did not eat meat in fact
humans only started eating meat at after
Noah I mean maybe they did before but
they they were only allowed to eat meat
after Noah so meet the the coming of
eating of flesh is seen as part of the
fall so it's like this falling into
flesh so eating flesh is also the
falling into flesh and so the the idea
that fasting would be an abstaining from
meat is to put ourselves back into the
move towards the original state you
would say um so that that is that but
the meat is not it's not bad there's
nothing wrong with eating meat it is
completely acceptable and it is and it
is completely fine and in that whole
problem is finally actually resolved in
communion communion resolved the problem
of Genesis and flesh and because we eat
the flesh of the divine logos in the
form of bread and so we actually go back
into the garden
but we bring all the death all that
stuff from the outside we bring it into
the garden so we join everything
together um so I hope that helps you to
understand that
so Paul Renee Nichols for $50 you asked
my goodness Wow that's that's we kind of
you just want to say thank you for
leading me to orthodoxy I keep you in my
prayers keep up the good work well thank
you Paul because I definitely need your
prayers that's for sure
and I appreciate them very much all
right drew McMann asks for $4.99 so you
can focus too much on your body can you
focus too much on your soul for sure for
sure for sure you can focus too much on
your soul not only can you focus too
much on your soul but the first sin is a
sin of the soul is not a sin of the body
the sins of the body come after st.
Maximus the Confessor I think I've
mentioned this quote one of my favorite
quotes from - Maximus the Confessor
where he says that you know there's the
sins of the right hand and the sins of
the left hand and the sins of the right
hand consists in pride self sufficiency
these are sins of the soul there are
sins of thinking that you what you
identify is you your thoughts your
identity your personality all of these
things that they're the top that they're
the they're the they're the top of of
the hierarchy that there is nothing
which gives that that the light doesn't
come from above right the light comes
from my own reason my own thinking my
own self and that's the first sin and
same axis says that when we give in to
the sins of the soul the sins of the age
of pride then comes in the sins of the
body it starts with pride and you see it
in the case of Satan you see it in the
case of Adam you see it in the case of
Cain every firsts all these first sins
are always since a pride but then comes
the murder of Abel then comes
not the sin of the body but let's say in
terms of terms of Adam and Eve you know
Adam sins and then then after that comes
their conjugal union between Adam and
Eve and so this falling into the body is
a consequence of the sin now in the case
of the conjugal union it's actually not
seen as a sin in itself but it's still
seen as a consequence of of the fall all
of that like I said though is going to
be changed into glory as much the murder
because we have Christ being murdered on
the cross and as much the conjugal union
because we have the entire imagery of
the Christ as the groom and the church
as the bride and this whole Union which
takes that imagery and lifts it up you
could say so for sure you can focus too
much on your soul and I would say that
focusing too much on your soul is it's
probably one of the bigger dangers right
now and because the the problem the
problem is this the problem is that if
you're living in the body if you are
completely taken up by the passions of
the flesh you know by your desires for
sex or whatever for food or for you know
just that you are lying all the time
that you're stealing that you're
murdering all these things that that you
that are really like you know taking
things and killing people and whatever
all of that then it can actually be
helpful to focus on the soul that is it
can be helpful to move into the soul and
so by by finding a purpose by getting a
job by having friends by doing all that
stuff you know the kind of during
Petersons stuff that he suggests then
you can solve the problem of the body
but you can't stop there do you stop
there then you're gonna fall again
it's gonna be a cycle maybe it could be
a long cycle but it's you're gonna
you're gonna you're the chances that you
tumble back are quite strong and so
that's why we need to move up towards
the higher aspects and that's where the
spiritual disciplines come into play
that's where prayer comes into play
that's where also submitting yourself to
something in a hierarchy to someone who
is responsible for you spiritually
because that person let's say acts as
something which is beyond your own
thought and your own your own emotions
and can mirror for you your news because
he's above you you know like a priest um
all that is helpful to kind of help you
move up so that you don't run into the
problems of the soul but the problems of
the soul and those are the the you know
you can do everything through pride you
can anything that you do you can do
through pride and so it's that's the
last sin and a certain extent it's the
it's the syndicate that takes you down
and it's the last sin to go because you
can love other people you can be nice
you can help the poor you can do all of
everything that you do you can do
through a sense of self sufficiency and
it and it it's on it's around every
corner but as soon as you give in to
that self sufficiency it comes the
snakes again you can't avoid that as
well so I hope that answer is that all
right let me just see I just wanted to
okay so Jonathan asks do you admit you
differ on certain symbolic
interpretations at all also should one
consciously seek to embody certain sub
all like manifestations ie the fool
I would say mattoon I have have small
differences we definitely I would say we
have way more in common than we do have
differences I
say that one of the differences between
my tear and I is that he is more he's
he's smarter than I am and he also he
has a capacity for abstract thinking
that I that I don't have and so he sees
I think the patterns more purely than I
do but but then the negative side of
that is that I think that I tend to be
more prone to give a lot of examples and
to to that in some respects I'm capable
of pulling people in because I
constantly giving examples and I'm
constantly trying to give as many
examples as I can so I I kind of maybe
speak closer to the way that most people
think but but ultimately I do think that
materias a clear perception of the
patterns and has a clear perceptions of
the the subtleties of these patterns so
and by the way guys if any of you have
not read Matthew's book yet like what
are you waiting for you need to you need
to read it before his other books come
out so it's called it's called oh man
alright okay so you guys can follow me
to Padua Platt you can find his book on
on Amazon alright so Gabriel are four
five dollars ask could you elaborate a
bit more on the centrality and
importance of language you say language
is the foundation of thought um I mean
it's it's the it's the expression of
thought it's maybe a better way to
explain it it's the expression of
pattern it's the communication of
pattern it's the way in which the
principles exterior exterior eyes like
become exterior and so so I don't know
if it's the foundation of thought but it
definitely is the way in which thought
manifests itself so you could you can
imagine it like that that the
you could say it this way that the way
to explain it would be something like
that the entire creation existed in the
thought the mind of God in all eternity
and then the actual realization of those
thoughts happened in the speaking and so
let there be is the way in which the
patterns appear in the world through a
let there be you know a name also
pointing you know that kind of stuff
where all the sudden things come
together but the the the divine pattern
the divine thought is I think proceeds
the the I mean precedes my goodness if I
say that people are going to you can see
you could really see it as as God the
Father as as let's say the silence in
which the infinite is silent and then
the son or the logos as the
exteriorization of of the divine into
the world
um that's this way I'm gonna get to it
alright so Geoffrey Stuart for five
dollars oh man
so Jeffrey Stern asked what do you think
of Mormonism especially specifically
their wearing garments and the symbols
in their underwear I do I don't know
about this I know I know I have Mormon
to watch me I know that some of you
latter-day signs people watch my videos
I I have to be honest with you I I don't
think that Mormonism is a valid
tradition
I think Mormonism is a
I think Mormonism is a is a strange
twisting of of the Christian tradition
and so because of it there are some
things in Mormonism which are not false
there are some things which shine
brightly there are some things which are
which actually cap to capture some
truths about Christianity but there are
also some aspects of Mormonism which I
think are not are not Christian and are
or something else sorry guys
all right so let's see keep refreshing
these super chat so TJ gecko for $10 as
someone with 18 years of Catholic
education I'm somewhat upset that you're
the first person to ever explain it's
not this way
even they had even they had something
like image here this view dude I look I
know I know I know in death and III as
simply for you I I feel I understand
because I think so many of us have had
that experience but I think it's
important to understand that like I'm
not making it out I I'm yet I think that
we haven't neglected some of the church
fathers people have neglected the the
more profound church fathers angry or
Missa st. Maximus the Confessor sent out
from the Syrian the deeper aspects even
in people's like Athanasius or st. in
Italy on or I think that it's all there
but I think that so many of us have
forgotten it and the difficulty that we
have when there's a change of worldview
is that we often don't you don't
perceive it it's happening under our
feet and very few people are able to
perceive it that's one of the things
that I when I talk about Galileo and I
when you look at what happened with
Galileo you realize that
there was a change that happened there
was a shift in the very manner in which
people saw the world and by the time
they were arguing with Galileo it was
too late the ancient world was gone
and no one knew what they were they had
lost something and then they were
arguing with Galileo on a terrain that
wasn't that wasn't the right terrain to
argue on and so and so I think that one
of the reasons why we're able to do this
like one of the reasons why now there's
this moment where I can talk about this
and you guys can understand and let's
you can talk about this and Metz you can
understand to a certain extent
Jordan Peterson was talking about some
of these things and and and people are
understanding but then now I'm starting
to find other people that have been
trying to talk about these things in a
way that that people can understand is
is really I hate to say this but it's
because of post-modernism post-modernism
what it did is that it shattered the
modern Hall hold on our perceptions it
kind of shattered that vision and it
broke it broke it in in a thousand
pieces and what it didn't realize is
that among those thousand of pieces
there are a few of the pieces that had
of what was left there were some gems
which could be found again that couldn't
be seen before so we so we we all the
son could now in a way that you know our
ancestors even a hundred years ago could
we're looking back at the Christian
tradition and there's some things which
were veiled to their eyes because of the
very worldview that they were inhabiting
now that that worldview is broken
there's all this chaos there's all this
madness because of it but it is now
possible to look back and see things
that were not seen by our immediate
ancestors and I think that that's the
surprise
of post-modernism and and and that's the
that's the that's the problem of the you
know this idea when I talk about this
double inversion where there's a trick
like this there's a trick in in in the
Gospels of the trick in the Bible
there's a trick in that should the idea
of the crucifixion itself which is that
you know the story that you see in the
gospel of nicodemus and we see in the
image of the honest Ossus of the
resurrection of Christ where you know
the devil and the Hades are in hell and
they're waiting for Christ to die on the
cross I know and they're they're
boasting and they're bragging and
they're thinking we've done it you know
we finally arrived we've killed the
logos but then bringing the logos down
into the chaos then the logos shines
into the chaos and I think that that's
what happened modernism tried to destroy
Christianity but as it actually resolved
as it came to the very end where it
actually thought that it had succeeded
and the last thing left I've talked
about before the last thing left was
consciousness itself that they tried to
swallow
you know the qualities of things
themselves the Logie themselves they
thought they could swallow them in
darkness and pop here they come again
so that's the way I see it guys that's
the way I see it all right let's see all
right I need to review to refresh this
again sorry guys I'm really not good
with these super chat stuff okay so shot
in the dark asks my wife and I will be
having a first child in the next few
weeks can you comment on the symbolism
of the firstborn or firstfruits yeah I
mean sure yeah
I mean I can comment about it in a way
that you might not expect I like to do
that as you notice that one of the
interesting things about Christianity is
that it is a restoration of the
firstborn this is something that I've
been thinking about for a long time I'll
probably do a video on it as well but um
if you look in the Bible there's this
idea of the firstborn right this idea of
the firstborn but if you look at how the
story actually plays out
it's the firstborn is it's always the
second it's it's it's the second it's
you know it's Abel it's it's Jacob or
it's not even a second you know it's
Joseph it's not the first first has been
lost in the fall it's as if the fall is
is is is it is the losing of the
firstborn and so you know when you see
that Christ is the the firstborn of all
creation you have to understand that it
actually is is clashing with the
biblical story because in the biblical
story it's always never the firstborn
even though there is this idea of the
firstborn that you see the idea that the
firstborn will inherit the idea that the
the the firstfruits I need to be given
up to God all of this is there but but
Christ restores that you know and and if
you know once you understand that Christ
restores the firstborn you'll understand
a lot of things you can understand why
it is Rome which converted to
Christianity because Rome is Esau Rome
is Cain you know Rome is the killing of
the brother and the founding of the city
just like Cain and so in the very story
Christianity seems like it was
inevitable that it would be Rome or
something a kid into Rome which would
finally which would convert in this
restoration of the firstborn so here's a
little mystery for you guys
all right hmm okay so Kristian Kristian
Chad asks so he's so this mad truth guy
keeps trying to post but I don't see his
his post for some reason so sorry I
don't know why that's happening I know
if you if you're being censored or
whatever but so Christian Chad says the
mad truth asks you don't support
revolution and say perfect form of
government is monarchical with Christ as
king but Kings Christ our sin and
corruptible and so revolutions are
necessary inevitable to flip the corrupt
system um so this is an interesting idea
it's an interesting thing to think about
and it's an interesting problem and I
agree that Kings are corruptible and
that kings are can be subject to sin and
that hierarchies are corruptible now the
problem is
what kind of revolution is acceptable
that's really the problem it's not that
revolutions are inevitable
the problem with revolutions is that
they they rarely give they really give
what they think they give there are
stories of revolutions in in in
tradition now the best story of
revolution is the story of King David
that is that is that is the Bible trying
to work out the problem of revolution
and that ultimately actually gets
resolved in Christ ultimately but in the
story of King David you already see a
desire to resolve the problem of
revolution because the problem with
revolution in general is that it's a
it's a toss up it's like turning the
table and that the idea that the next
king or the next leader is gonna be any
better than the one before is really a
gamble there is no guarantee because
they say they're gonna be better you
know
Robespierre was know we're better no
error Napoleon was in no way better than
we the 14th and so and it's the same
with the Russian Revolution it's the
same with most revolutions is that they
end up with worse than before so then
how do you restore how do you reboot how
do you so in the Bible there are several
ways that there's an attempt to do that
one is the Jubilee the Jubilee is a
desire to avoid the problem you're
talking about the Sabbath is that as
well the Jubilee especially because in
the Jubilee what you have is you have a
let's say 250 year period where things
organized in this hierarchy of property
and this hierarchy of power and then at
the end of the 50 years the power is
then devolved back into its original
this
tribution you would say so what it does
is it avoids the pyramid getting too
pointy in too hard and then every 50
years you break it apart so that it
doesn't get too harsh okay
now that that the Jubilee is it is a
desire to do that on the store of King
David the beauty of the story of King
David is that King Saul falls into sin
and becomes an evil King tyrannical king
so the idea is there has to be a change
now how do we know that the king who's
going to replace Saul in a revolution is
going to be the right king and the
answer in the story of King David is
very powerful because the answer in the
story King David is that it's the one
who refuses to kill the king it's like
I'm getting shivers just thinking about
it it's like that is the solution the
one who is to be the king is the one who
refuses to kill the king and and that's
the way to know which king is the one to
replace the corrupt one and that's what
happened in the story King David King
David replaces Saul but the whole time
that he's ascending that the whole the
whole time of his ascent he refuses to
kill Saul even when he has a chance to
do it and I think that's the that's
ultimately ends up being the answer that
Christianity offers which is you know if
you look at the best stories of in the
hierarchy of the church there are
horrible stories but the ones that we
hold to be the ideal ones the ones that
we hold to be the highest are the ones
where the Bishop let's say or the abbot
of a monastery is the one that's chosen
is the one who refuses to become the
bishop the one who flees physically
flees away when they tried to put him in
office and they have to go get him in
his cave and bring him back and say no
you're the bishop and then they're like
no I don't want to be the bishop like no
or the bishop those always under being
the best the best bishops that's that's
that that's the way I see the solution
to that guys all right so Christian Chad
also said the magic word continues is
democracy not preferred with revolution
built in every four years
it's amok recei not preferred preferred
to depend referred to what preferred to
monarchy
maybe it's preferable to absolute
monarchy but I don't believe in absolute
monarchy I'm not an absolute monarchist
i I believe in I believe that something
like the Byzantine Empire tried to find
a balance between the powers of the
state the powers of the church and the
Emperor figure was not always because
not always a direct succession there are
possibilities of breaks in the
succession the idea that you know it's
only the descendants of one family
forever is a silly idea there are
possibilities of breaks in that
succession so the problem with democracy
is the problem with democracy is that it
devolved into devolves into chaos and
then it actually brings about tyranny
because and that's what Plato said and I
think that there are many examples and
they're an example in Germany in the
1930s which is that when democracy
breaks down because there are too many
factions and there are too many people
who are and there's too strong and
opposition within the factions then that
can either devolve into civil war or it
will devolve into a tyranny and just
it hasn't happened yet I mean you know
and thank God for that
what happened once in the u.s. although
it hasn't happened since the Civil War
there's nothing to say they won't happen
again
especially if you look at how tense the
situation is right now in the u.s. there
is a need I think for Transpo trans
political characters yeah
all right so the people's front of Judea
for $5.00 for Monty Python all right so
what is the day he is actually asking
about my tip I thought what is the
orthodox christian view on the Monty
Python film The Life of Brian the
position of Catholic priest is that it's
blasphemous opinion I don't know what
that official I don't think the Orthodox
have any official view on that on that
movie I would say it's I would say that
movie is half blasphemous and half
hilarious I mean it's a pretty funny
movie but I think that for sure some of
it is seems to at least court with
blasphemy but it's it's really funny
especially the the whole much Python my
goodness they had such incisive capacity
to understand cultural movements and
cultural dynamics in that movie that
whole idea of these different
revolutionary groups that can't get
along with each other and are fighting
more amongst each other than they are
fighting against the authority is is
wonderful yeah that whole that whole
discussion about the guy who wants to be
who wants to be a woman cuz he wants to
have babies and then they'll defend his
right to be a woman my goodness I mean
it was that movie really made in the 70s
I guess could only have been made or in
the 80 I don't know when it was made
late early 80s maybe it would only have
been made at that time because because
today he could never make a movie like
that but it's hilarious
all right so so Vesuvius asks what's the
status of God's dog so it's coming along
so the difficulty with God's dog is that
court Nielson who's the artist working
on it I mean he is being amazing about
it and the images that are coming out of
it when I post the talk I gave in
Chicago I actually give people a sneak
peak of some of the pages that he's
putting out the difficulty is that he
has a full-time job and you know he's
doing it in his spare time and you know
I'm not in a position right now to
finance the to like you know hire him
full-time for him to make the comic and
and he also just had a baby like a few
months ago and so that that has slowed
him down but we're still working I get
we we still we're still working on the
different pages we're still moving along
it is going to take a little longer but
we won't give up on that project because
it's gonna happen now my hope is that
when it's ready we're going to we're
going to crowdfund the printing for it
but what I'm hoping is that if people if
people really get behind us and and and
are willing to support the project that
we'll be able to raise enough money to
finance the second book because it's a
really it's a it's an epic story and I
think there's going to be at least four
or five books in the series and so what
we hope is that if we can get enough
momentum going that then he could quit
his job and if we could finance the the
second book and then we could speed
things up and so well well you guys will
see the the images from that soon it's
really it's really he's really doing a
great job and he's really I feel like
he's really understanding the ideas that
were bringing in there and he
understands the characters very well I'm
excited like I even though even though I
know it's taking longer than what any of
us had would have hoped for even himself
I'm really excited about it and looking
forward to looking forward to present it
to you guys when we get close to when we
get close to the time when we're
actually going to do a crowdfunding for
the print
I'll start making videos about it and
I'll start doing more explicit videos
about st. Christopher and maybe do a
video with cord as the artist and I'll
try to kind of integrate that into my
content so that you guys get a bit more
of a sneak peek of what's happening
okay so Eleanor is asked them what are
the meanings of anarcho-capitalism and
anarcho-communism besides that they're
deluded what to say
they're completely deluded
anarcho-capitalist and anarchic and I
could communist my goodness with that is
just the most insane delusion people who
people who come up with those ideas
really honestly can only have lived in
Western world in Western countries I
mean yeah I've seen anarchy I've seen it
with my eyes and it doesn't at all look
like what they think
anarchy looks like if there are no there
are no hierarchies then it's just a
bunch of people fighting amongst
themselves and it can devolve to
different levels but it will always
evolve and evil will fight if and if
people think that it's just a cultural
thing in the sense that other cultures
would do it that way but us in the West
we wouldn't do it that way if we had
such a system you know not that long ago
our cultures were also fighting amongst
themselves and you know tribes were
fighting each other and so yeah I don't
believe in that stuff there's not a lot
of solutions though pulp politically I
mean I'm not I'm not
I'm not delusional myself like I'm not
saying there are easy political
solutions and when I say that I'm that I
believe in a form of monarchy I also see
it in it
I'm only presenting to you guys my ideal
I'm not sure that there can be such a
thing as monarchy in a technological
world because it would be difficult
to imagine how it went evolve into a
form of tyranny because one of the one
of the strengths of monarchy in the past
was the idea of having a figure that had
something like near absolute power and
very little reach and so they had to
negotiate with their with the
aristocracy with the people below them
in the hierarchy because they couldn't
they couldn't affect the world directly
from from where they stood and so that
tended to create a kind of balance but
in a world where you have surveillance
states and where you have the capacity
to spy on everybody and to control
everybody you know of course like I said
guys I don't know what the political
solution is that's why I don't focus on
the political solution try to focus on
on a spiritual solution and I and
hopefully out of that will come will
come political solutions that will be
viable and this is feel like this is
ending on a depressing depressing note
what is going on all right guys I think
we're gonna end it's like almost 11:00
anyways usually I try to go for now in
half but um but alright guys thank you
so much for showing up I really
appreciate the opportunity that you guys
give me to talk about this stuff mmm I'm
I'm excited to see how the faith how the
YouTube channels been growing I'm
excited to see the Facebook group
growing and all the great discussions
that are happening all this stuff that's
going on I'm excited to see even the
discussions that are happening between
the different people like even you know
like John for Vicki and that Paul van
der Clay and the fact that I you know
even Reb a wisdom that I just did this
talk with Joran greenhalgh get all these
discussions that it seems like we're not
weren't that possible a few years ago so
I'm just excited about all this and I
think all of you for giving us the
opportunity to talk about that and to uh
to discuss and to duke it out and to try
to get to the bottom of all this stuff
so so so I thank you and I'm going to
sign off
alright guys see you in a month